Welcome to you, our listener, as we open the book, The Master and the Disciple, to examine a profound teaching where a Sheikh refuses every name the disciple offers and makes him wait seven days, like a newborn, before naming him.
The name is your owner, and you are owned by it, for you cannot rise beyond your own spiritual rank.
Our mission is a slow, deliberate, and in-depth exploration of episode 12 of the text, where the young man finally meets the greater teacher.
So this is how the encounter opens.
Praise be to Allah, who split the dark obscurity of hearts with his light, who out of his justice imposed upon his creatures only what they could bear.
He harmoniously balanced his command between the two, doing what he commanded and refraining from what he forbade and named it justice.
Creation is incapable of repaying the burden of what he deserves for all his blessings, yet he is only displeased by them when they are ungrateful.
He exists everywhere, but not within boundaries.
He is known but cannot be described.
He exists yet cannot be seen.
He is recognized but cannot be fully known.
The honor of people's intellect is its use in searching for Allah.
Among the rewards of seeking Him is finding Him, and a sign of having found Him is experiencing the sweetness of His presence.
His distinctive sign is the truth, and the duties flowing from that truth are obligatory, as Allah Himself has said.
We will show them our signs in the universe and in their own selves until it becomes manifest to them that this is the truth.
Chapter 41, verse 53, translation by Sahih International, the Noble Quran.
Listen carefully to the architecture of that praise because
Hearing that frame being set before a single question is even asked is just, it's entirely staggering.
It really is.
I mean, it creates this vast, almost incomprehensible landscape.
It immediately puts the human intellect in its proper, humbled position.
Because human nature instinctively wants to put a boundary on things to understand them.
We want to define, categorize, and capture.
But the text shatters that impulse right at the threshold.
It states clearly that he exists everywhere, but not within boundaries.
Yeah, the intellect is honored not by capturing the divine, which is
but by the sheer act of searching.
And the sign of actually finding isn't some rigid academic certainty.
The sign is sweetness.
The duties flow from truth.
It is an entire cosmic orientation given to the mind before the dialogue truly begins.
It sets the absolute necessary orientation for everything that follows, forcing you to completely abandon your ego before crossing the doorway.
And this perdition of the opening sermon
Carefully setting the limits of human comprehension mirrors the sermons of the father of imams, peace be upon him.
Those profound teachings carry this exact same cadence of awe and intellectual humility.
They are preserved by al-Sharif al-Radi in the book The Peak of Eloquence.
Compiled in the late 4th century after the historical migration, or hijra,
That book uses the exact same linguistic architecture.
The praise must first name the absolute limits of describing the praise before taking up any other matter.
I mean, you cannot learn until you admit what you cannot know.
The collection gathers several such openings, and they all serve to systematically humble the listener.
And that humbling is entirely necessary for what happens next.
Absolutely.
So the disciple and the scholar finally arrive at the physical door of the Sheikh.
We have to pause and feel the weight of this exact moment.
His earlier teacher, the scholar, has been the spiritual father thus far.
He has guided his student through all prior doctrine, given him his foundation and shaped his worldview.
But now he has reached the limit of his own rank.
He has to hand his student over to the greater teacher.
He steps aside, becoming a mere witness.
Which sets the stage for an incredibly tense first exchange.
The Sheikh does not ask about his difficult journey, his previous studies, or the doctrines he has memorized.
No, he looks at him and simply asks, oh brave youth, what is your name?
And the young man answers with the shared theological formula, slave of a law.
Son of the slave of Allah.
I don't buy that yet.
Why is a grown man's name dismissed as a description?
Because it is entirely universal and therefore it hides his specific reality.
It states a basic ontological fact of creation.
In this tradition, being a servant of the divine is a condition every single human being and Adam shares.
It is the baseline of existence.
Exactly.
Not an identity of a specific spiritual rank.
The sheik looks right through this defense and tells him directly, that is your description, not your name.
So the disciple is forced to try again, digging deeper into his spiritual resume.
He says, then I am the freedman, son of the servant.
That sounds like wordplay.
Isn't this just replacing one teacher with a grander one?
He is claiming a specific historical event of being liberated.
Yeah, he's pointing directly to his education and his prior teacher, the scholar standing right there, as the source of his new elevated identity.
He is essentially saying, I have graduated.
But the sheik dissects this claim instantly, and the resulting exposure is devastating.
He asks, who set you free?
The young man proudly points to the scholar standing beside him.
And the sheik replies, but if your teacher is
by another and does not own you, has he any right to free you?
It is a brilliant, terrifying unmasking.
The Sheikh is pointing out that the scholar is himself bound by his own rank, his own limits, his own master.
A prisoner cannot grant ultimate freedom to another prisoner.
The disciple hangs his head.
He is utterly silenced.
And we really have to foreground the immense felt weight of this exposure.
This is not meant as an insult to his former teacher.
It is a total necessary exposure
of the student's illusion of arrival.
We can view it as the bottom of the cup.
Every linguistic defense, every conventional identity, every badge of honor he brought with him to that door has been systematically stripped away.
He has no answer left.
The silence that follows is heavy, and because he is at the bottom of the cup, finally empty, true teaching can begin.
Stripping away those comfortable layers reveals his total, absolute dependence.
He realizes he is entirely without definition in this new, vast space.
He has no rank to lean on.
In a moment of pure surrender, the young man says,
I have been born to you, so give me a name.
The Sheik's profound response to that total surrender is the pivot of the entire encounter.
He tells the disciple that the naming cannot happen immediately.
It can only happen after the completion of seven days.
He is treating him exactly like a newborn, waiting seven days for its name.
How is this different from any initiation that simply withholds the secret until the apprentice waits out the clock?
It's a valid pushback, but it is not a test of endurance or a theatrical trick.
It is an exact alignment with the deepest rhythms of reality.
Grounding this practice, we see it is not arbitrary at all.
This is the living practice of the Prophet, peace, and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
The precise protocol for the newborn is preserved by the hadith compiler, Sunan Abu Dawud.
The early collector meticulously recorded that the physical child must be named on the 7th day.
By enforcing this agonizing weight, that compiler shows us how the tradition prescribes the exact protocol for physical birth.
which the Sheikh is now flawlessly applying to this spiritual rebirth.
The disciple cannot bypass the incubation.
And there is a massive cosmic weight attached to that number 7 in this text that goes far beyond a simple week on a calendar.
The universe itself receives life through the divine command B, whose 7th letter begins life.
Furthermore, physical creation itself occurs in seven distinct, unbreakable stages.
We see this explicitly when looking at chapter 23 verses 12 through 14.
The text details those exact stages with biological precision.
The creation moves first from a quintessence of clay, which then becomes a drop in a secure place.
Then the drop becomes a clinging clot.
The clot becomes a lump.
The lump becomes bones.
The bones are then clothed with flesh.
And finally, the human is brought forth as another creation entirely.
I have to concede that point.
Hearing the biological progression laid out perfectly mirrors this spiritual completion.
If you imagine the reality of an embryo in the dark of the womb, moving from a clot to a lump to bones, it is a blind, vulnerable and entirely dependent process.
The embryo cannot rush its own development.
It cannot declare itself finished.
The stages of the embryo physically reflect exactly what is happening to the young man spiritually in those seven days of silence.
Completion.
absolutely must precede naming.
You cannot rush biology and you cannot rush spiritual formation.
And when the disciple tests the boundary with one more question, asking if he will actually own this new name once the seven days are complete, the sheet gives him the governing principle of his existence.
He replies that he will not.
The name is your owner and you are owned by it.
For you cannot rise beyond your own spiritual rank.
That completely shatters the premise of human ego.
We assume a name is a tool we wield, a label we own and manipulate for our own prestige.
But a spiritual rank defines your absolute limit.
He cannot reach above it by merely wishing or studying.
The rank itself is the structural boundary that holds him safely in place.
To own a name is to be the one worshipped, to be the absolute sender.
To be owned by it is to accept your exact, designated place in the intricate architecture of reality.
The narrative tells us that after the agonizing 7 days finally pass, the young man undergoes a complete physical ablution.
He washes away the dust of his former life.
He is dressed in his finest garment, prepared as if for a wedding or a final passage.
The sheik draws him physically close and begins the transmission of knowledge
Speaking of unseen realities that cannot be comprehended by the raw imagination, realities of which pens would completely fail to write.
The disciple then steps out to perform the physical ritual.
He goes to the house and he suples the Kaaba 7 times.
He performs the circumambulation.
Why overlay this elaborate inner meaning onto an established, purely physical ritual?
Millions of people perform that exact movement.
Why are we reading the specific walk as a profound mystical map rather than just a standard religious obligation?
To understand the staggering depth of what the source is unfolding here, we must look at the classical Ismarali reading of this physical act.
We have to be mindful of positionality, noting scholars like Henry Corbin, who spent his life mapping out esoteric traditions, and Farhad
who meticulously traced the doctrines?
They point out that the outer right is read as a literal physical performance of an inner invisible orientation.
When you look at the physical mechanics of this Tawaf, you are essentially watching planets orbiting their sun.
It is gravity acting as love.
Consider what that actually means in terms of physics and spirituality.
The physical circling becomes a living map of the soul's relation to the imam.
The sun represents the imam at the absolute center, massive, radiant, and holding the system together.
The young man is the small planet caught in the dark but pulled inward by the immense gravitational field of love.
A planet doesn't consciously decide to orbit.
It is bound by an invisible, undeniable force to a center it can never actually reach.
The intense stakes of this orbit cannot be overstated.
An orbit is a paradox of physics.
It is the act of constantly falling toward the center while moving sideways fast enough to keep missing it.
The love is that relentless pull inward.
The orbit is not just a path, it is the disciples' very life.
Think about the physical reality of space.
To break free and leave the orbit is to drift away into the cold, silent void, losing the center entirely, which is spiritual death by isolation.
But to fall directly toward the center is to be completely incinerated and consumed by the heat.
which is spiritual death by overstepping your rank.
The orbit is the exact delicate shape in which love keeps the planet alive.
The 7 circuits he walks map the exact 7 stages by which his new life is given.
It is a profound recognition.
The young man ends up permanently bound to the center to which his name will always belong.
He is held securely by a force he cannot master, moving in a lane of obedience that gives him his life, his warmth, and his illumination.
It is a surrender that results in perfect placement.
He doesn't need to conquer the center.
He just needs to remain in the light.
To summarize this immense narrative arc, the disciple who began at the doorway completely unable to give his own true name, ends up named in a name he does not own.
He is drawn into a massive gravitational orbit he did not consciously choose, and he spends his life circling the exact center to which his name will always belong.
He finds his exact location in the universe, realizing that true freedom isn't escaping boundaries, but finding the right center to revolve around.
The name is your owner, and you are owned by it, but you cannot rise beyond your own spiritual rank.
Which name already given you your role as a parent?
Your obligations at work?
The limit of your actual rank have you been straining to rise above instead of standing inside?